[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des colorants pas marrants du
Maout dans les
océans et des trucs bizarres dans nos
assiettes pauvre
biftech la petite Juliette et son
Roméo tourne à poil dans les pin
il y a pas plus d'amour sur
pellicule que de fleurs sous le
bitum tu as beau pas être
beau mon de
singl je t'ai dans la
[Musique]
peau je
t'aime il y en a qui dégainent leur
pétard pour une poignée de
dollar il y a des des bombas et les
bombaches qui joue à
cache-cache il y a le KGB à la
c le gros Z
[Musique]
Amada du S à la Une des
gazettes pauvre planète
oh pas être
beau
moninglé j' Tai dans
la
je t'aime taime taime faut dire qu'il y
a quand même ch ch des mecs qu' ont du
soleil ch
ch dans la tête cher ch sur ma planète
ch chche des mecs qui pensent pas ch ch
que c'est chacun pour soi ch ch qui se
tend les bras ch sur ma terre à moi ch
ch
[Musique]
être
beau je t' la
peauut
[Musique]
Pastre
PE
[Musique]
être je t dans la
peau t'ae'' ta peau pas
[Musique]
être